on this episode we talk about the
supplying the man of content Twitter
polls and do I compete with others or
myself
[Music]
yes
dare you beat everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 166 of
the ask gary vee show just have a little
fun experiment on periscope
I'm gonna go back 40 50 okay the happens
faster what's up everybody glad to have
you back I'll let you watch the show
thank you for that before we we just
jumped on periscope at about 700 people
early on this Wednesday morning
pre-thanksgiving big shout out Happy
Thanksgiving to everybody who's
celebrating it in the US market very
quiet in the office today as people are
traveling and getting home Thank You
team for being here India tomorrow for
you you flying tomorrow today you're
saying so Happy Thanksgiving
you guys and decided to bang out a show
early this morning have a new video out
a new movie Stephan maybe you can play
it in parallel in an open space here for
a few seconds while we're talking this
this new movie speaks to Fitness
entrepreneurs I think that there's a lot
of people in the fitness entrepreneur
space hacking you know a lot of bull
crap on Instagram right now and and I
kind of wanted to call them out that
they're putting in the work for their
ABS their ass and their muscles but
they're not putting in the work for
their business I was pretty proud of it
I hope you guys check that out stephane
let's link that in a Facebook and
YouTube and share that up so fascinated
by the share virality in the Facebook
environment and want to find new
audiences so if you're a right hook here
if you like it and it's relevant please
share that up on your Facebook account
to India good to see you I'm in a little
bit of a better mood this morning as a
matter fact I may even make a Jets
prediction I decided I and I really
didn't think I was going to but some
people have motivated me truth is
actually don't know what's gonna happen
you've got two teams that are really
struggling and the Jets and the Dolphins
and so whatever AJ's here it's good to
see with the cage and so India you know
I think today I'm a little bit I'm not a
salty it sure wasn't quite salty a lot
of people liked it I didn't realize how
many people like the salt I mean salty
Vee
hashtag solving me you know what's
interesting I am scared to think what
the episode would have been on Monday
because I literally said I don't want to
do it which is the only time since we
started the show that I didn't do the
show when I could have the only time and
if you thought I was salty on Tuesday
imagine the salt I mean I was like I was
like the who the department that takes
care of stuff when it snows
samkisha yeah I mean literally the level
of salt that I was bringing on Monday is
like the New York City sanitation
department before a 28-inch storm of
snow I was real salty so I know you guys
enjoy it on Tuesday who knows what the
Monday version of it would have been but
India let's get into the show all right
Riley sorry I'm gonna better mood today
Riley asks do you think that content
marketing is watering down Internet
content with unimportant and false
information no I do not I think that
crappy and false information has always
existed it exists every single moment
that you live the amount of crap and
wrong information that is going to be
spewed at the dinner tables across
America tomorrow by family members to
each other is staggering uncle Rick is
gonna pound his fist about politics or
about football or about why Facebook is
bad you know or you know a million other
things tomorrow and so humans are really
good at having the ability to put out
crap and false information I think the
Internet just happens to be a place
where they dump that and so I don't
think content marketing has changed the
dynamic that will be around forever my
friends one of the good things about
watching my show is you can start
picking up themes because there's 20 to
50 pillars that I will play over these
175 episodes I plan on doing for the
show all time
kidding kidding and and I think the
thing that will probably if you really
pay attention you'll pick up on is I
don't think that many new things are
happening I just think there's a current
state that then allows humans to do
their thing and so yeah I I don't think
content marketing has created a bigger
supply of crap I think that supply of
crap has always existed
we're just communicating in different
places you like that one dia message not
the medium it's pretty consistent
pillars John asks after watching a
hundred and sixty-five episodes I was
wondering if you get more satisfaction
competing against yourself or versus
others I don't compete against myself at
all it's why I struggled with Fitness
which is I know are out of time because
I made a new fitness movie I don't know
if you guys heard it's the fine you can
put it right here and run in parallel
while I'm giving this answer I'll give
you a little room for editing I'm really
bad at competing myself so I'm not
trying to make this show better in
episode from 123 to now from 92 to now I
always love myself I'm always thinking
that it's good and then I'm good I know
it evolves but I'm not competed with
myself I'm really bad at that again back
to Fitness I didn't want to run a minute
faster or have 20 more pounds that
wasn't what it is I wrote a fitness
article about how I needed to be
accountable to somebody else that was my
hack I'm very good though competing
against other people I hate everybody
else that's putting up business content
podcast and video I want to destroy them
I hope all their podcast equipment melts
tomorrow and I want to be the only
person that talks about business in the
world left unless I get all the audience
I win you lose podcast McGee yay so you
know I think I think I compete against
other people that's what drives me
that's how I roll but I'm completely all
in on me and my team I you know the the
Jets have two or three former Patriots
on their team Steven Ridley Thompkins
right now I love them with all my heart
that logo goes off their helmet they go
somewhere else I despise them with all
my heart I'm very on Team me team my
things that I like and and I don't
compete within that self I compete
against everybody else around it and
funny
it's how I handle Vayner me
yeah well they're on my team they're my
employees I love them even though I
still love the employees that once work
here Claire mutual friend of ours you
love Claire so much I love Claire Stein
loved her with all my heart just not as
much as I used to
she says she wears the New York Times
logo now not the vaynermedia one I can't
help it I want to destroy clear now
Claire I love you but I want to destroy
you you know like that's just the way it
is that's the game mechanics that's how
I think and it's very real and it's
interesting when you get to really fall
in love with an employee you know that
has been with you we've had a couple
that with us for two three four years
that are recently leaving and it's very
painful for me I get sad super lower lip
you know like lower lip you know and but
I want to destroy their faces
the next moment because they're putting
on a different Jersey I just can't help
it it's just the truth yeah but you know
what's funny but I also and you guys
know this I still interact with them I
help them with their careers so even
though I get pissed at players after
they lose a game they go and shake the
other teams hands and they still get
really mad at that
truth is I'm a hypocrite because I do
that because I'm doing that behind the
scenes and so I felt compelled to share
that because I don't wanna be a
hypocrite pissing me off I wish I didn't
like I wish I could hold the line but
but I don't cuz I like them
I love me Claire but I hate you India
Jared asks Gary do you have any
questions that you don't know how to
answer for yourself yeah there are some
questions I don't know how to answer
myself the number one being when you pay
forward when you take 15 minutes to
speak to a former employee to help them
with their next career move because they
made a mistake and leaving Manor not you
Claire but like you know I question if
all this paying for doing the right
thing will I one day when I'm not the
height of my power and execution or when
I run out of time and don't achieve the
things that I should have achieved or
will I recon text and say cool I made
these things but I'm also a great person
and everybody showed up to my funeral
like I'm always wondering will I ever
have a moment where I become bitter or
regretful of the disproportion amount of
non value for me things that I do
be and and the question really becomes
and what you want a mime or full of [ __ ]
on that I want to buy the New York Jets
or that I want everybody show up to my
funeral
I have two very opposing pulling actions
in my life which is I want to be this
very likable noble great dude that
everybody talks about at the dinner
table I want all of you I literally this
is so sick I desperately want the three
of you to like tell your grandchildren
about this great man that you worked
with I mean it I really do I it's so
important to me but to do that you have
to do so many things that are not in
your best interest
financially in the short term and I'm
just curious the thing that I don't have
answered for myself is when I'm dying
and and I'd like to by the way I'd like
to not suddenly die I'd prefer to die a
little bit slower so I can ponder
because I like pondering when that's
happening or at least I think so so
right now maybe when I'm 104 me like
this shoot me in the head kids what I'm
pondering it I'm so curious on because
one's gonna have to give its we rely I
I'm trying to walk the tightrope and boy
I think I'm really doing a solid job but
I I'm not sure that question I don't
have answered for myself is if I'm like
am I gonna like the way I played it
because I'm consciously playing it I'm
so in tune to what's going on with me am
I gonna look back and be like the job
because every time you know I just
turned 40 I look back at 20 or 30 I look
back at the 30 or 40 and I guess that's
what I'll probably always do because
it's pretty consistent now is there's a
lot of good there's things you knit pick
I'm sure everybody does that the regrets
can I minimize the regrets because I
think having regret is the most
unfortunate thing meeting a 70 80 90 100
year-old who regrets regrets that they
didn't have more fun didn't spend more
time with their family that's the cliche
one but you'd be surprised how many
people regret not doing more for
themselves so I don't know it's kind of
intense
that's quite real that was really can i
what what are you trying to grow that
here
okay well I'll give you an update on the
shoes so earlier by the way what was a
friend
the beginning a show is I asked a bunch
of people to share the content it was at
um it was I got a hundred and fifty or
twenty was it cuz at one twenty two and
then we went to it's five twenty six so
it's quiet I would say cool video from
Rob Bono's Gary V Rob crassius bacon
sports in the house having a little Gary
V party over here want to know what do
you think about Twitter polls the
engagement monetizing them drop some
knowledge on me first of all the best
part about Rob is no joke that literally
felt like Rob I'm gonna we can predict
prediction you watched wrestling as a
kid that was literally like a wrestling
promo Rob's like this Thursday night at
the Civic Coliseum Gary Vee and I are
gonna throw down some Twitter polls I
think Twitter polls really work I've
been getting a lot of engagement
two or three that I've tested it's very
simple humans are basic they see like do
you think this person should be
president yes or no they click the
button engagements hi monetizing them I
think is a longtail play you're not
going to monetize them Rob Twitter will
monetize them it's on their platform
more engagement they'll run into their
metrics for you for me for others for
all of us it's an opportunity to engage
our audience on Twitter a little bit
more often I think if you can get really
good at it and get clever with your
questions there's or or win in a long
tail niche there's some real
opportunities and so and so I am I think
that uh I think that um I think that a
very smart Twitter poll strategy for
personalities on Twitter is a very good
place to go and a consistency to build a
cadence and a brand as the pollster on
the platform is the only extreme upside
for everybody else it's a nice tactic so
for four to five people in the world
they'll breakout is maybe a pull stir on
the platform and for everybody else it's
just a way to like get a look a little
more engagement out of your audience
though Twitter is not like Facebook
where that engagement then leads to a
proxy of more people seeing your tweets
everybody's seeing all of your content
maybe you win on less about how many
people see it but people paying more
attention to you because your polls made
you interesting to them and now they're
looking at all your content so I think
it's a very long tail value prop for
people Stefon asks Gary would you rather
travel back in time to meet your
ancestors or forward to meet your future
relatives hundred thousand percent go
backwards and meet my ancestors I'm also
the byproduct of being unfortunate in a
place where I didn't get to know three
of my four grandparents which is on the
low end I think so that kind of stinks
I knew two great grandparents which was
awesome but they died very early on
actually my great-grandmother died later
but what great grandfather died when we
first got here ago I was very close to
Shia and so I would go backwards because
I'm the cool thing about I mean they're
both cool because the thing you look for
it's all very selfish you're like oh my
God my great great great granddaughter
is so similar to me and like does things
or but for me I don't know I like I like
the backwards I'd like to see like my
grandfather's to see what they're like
to see what I pulled from them my
great-great-great grandfather and
grandmother I'd like to see like where
it came from for me and so that's what I
would that's what I would do
cool that was it it's awesome that was a
nice kind of family thing a very smart
strategy in the I don't know if there
was that your strategy yeah it was very
good smart strategy have a have a
wonderful wonderful Thanksgiving really
really enjoy a question of the day is
where are you going to share and spend
your Thanksgiving in the US market and
for anybody outside the US market what
do you think the Jets Dolphin score is
going to be and then for everybody who
has no idea what American football is
just say hello yeah prediction thirteen
twelve dolphins another and that's just
yeah it's just gonna be traffic yeah I
don't even I don't even know if that's
you know what not a good that's not a
prediction that's not a prediction I
know I said it it's not a prediction
because I just said it but you had a
real prediction like
can't get motivated to make a prediction
I don't feel in tune
I feel attitude so there's no prediction
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]